we're joined on the line by vice
presidents of the united states mike
pence
uh thank you ben great to be back on the
bench bureau show so
let's talk about the fact that joe biden
has now selected his vice presidential
candidate
uh in a decision that surprised very few
people it was kamala harris the senator
from california so your thoughts on the
person you will now be facing in the
soul vice presidential debate
i think the fact that joe biden named
california
liberal senator kamala harris as his
running mate
confirms everything president trump and
i have been saying
that joe biden and the democratic party
have been overtaken
by the radical left i mean joe biden and
kamala harris
want higher taxes socialized medicine
open borders
abortion on demand and and they support
cutting
funding to the police i think i think
senator uh kamala harris actually said
that it was time to
re-imagine the police department in the
wake of
all the violence that we're seeing in
places like portland and seattle and new
york city
and the president and i by contrast have
a record of cutting taxes
uh rolling back regulations at an
unprecedented level
unleashing american energy standing up
for the right to life
for the liberties that make this country
great and i promise you and your
listeners ben
that we will always stand with the men
and women who serve on the thin blue
line of law enforcement that's the
choice that's the contrast
but joe biden's selection uh of uh of
senator
kamala harris just again i just think
it's an affirmation of everything that
we've seen about
the way the radical left is dominating
the democratic party
that's the message i had in iowa
yesterday we're going to take that
message
on the road next week to wisconsin and
florida
all across this country and all the way
through victory on november 3rd now vice
president pence
there's been a lot of talk about how
vice presidential selections generally
don't
affect elections overall that it's top
of the ticket election i don't think
that's the case this time
biden has declared himself a
transitional figure in the democratic
party by picking kamala harris he's
essentially
said that he himself is a trojan horse
for kamala harris's ideology 60
of americans according to rasmussen poll
are suspicious that biden will not even
finish his first term
how important do you think his vp pick
actually is to the american people
should it matter
well i think joe biden's agenda of the
radical left
confirmed in his selection of someone
who was recognized as the most
liberal member of the united states
senate
in 2019 is is the real issue here
then i i really believe that when when
if you want to if you want to know what
joe biden is planning to transition
us to in this country you you need to
look no further
than the unity agenda that he
and bernie sanders unveiled about a
month ago
i mean i mean the reality is where
president trump
set this nation on a path of freedom and
opportunity grounded in the principles
of a
strong military free market economics
appointing conservatives to our course
at every level
the joe biden bernie sanders unity
agenda would set us
inexorably on a path of socialism and
decline
and so i i think you know
as i said before i think his selection
of uh
of senator kamala harris is just a
confirmation
of of the path that joe biden and
his candidacy were on from the point
early in
in his campaign i mean it's an amazing
thing you know that that
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside the most pro-life president
in the united states and ben i've always
admired your strong stand for the
sanctity of life
and joe biden was one of those democrats
throughout his career
that while he said he supported abortion
rights that like many
he supported the hyde amendment which
prevented taxpayer dollars from being
used
to pay for abortions but even that joe
biden abandoned
over the last year that now he supports
taxpayer funding of abortion is calling
for record increases in funding for
planned parenthood
of america and it's just one issue after
another where you see that joe biden and
the democratic party have been overtaken
by the radical left that's why the
choice in this election has never been
clearer the stakes have never been
higher and that's the message
that the president that that his running
mate
uh that's talking to you right now are
going to take all across this country
and i and i believe
i believe we're going to we're going to
see a great victory a great victory
coming up
vice president pence how do you plan to
pin down kamala harris on her position
so the media have already been
been shockingly attempting to portray
her as moderate the new york times
laughably called her a pragmatic
moderate in its initial tweet
about kamala harris again she is the
left-most senator
in the united states they're trying to
proclaim that she's actually of the
center but kamala harris has an
extraordinary
record of shifting her positions on
everything from medicare for all she was
for it before she was against it before
she was sort of for before she was
against it
again to joe biden himself who she
essentially impli
implied was a racist and open debate who
was attempting to stop her
from attending an integrated school when
she was a small child now of course
he's a warrior for the people how do you
plan to pin kamala harris down when she
has been so squishy on so many issues
well you know my second favorite
president is abraham lincoln in fact i
have a portrait in my office here at the
white house
that was dated back from uh the days of
his administration abraham lincoln said
it best ben he said
give the people the facts and the
republic will be saved
that's what we're to do that's what
we're going to do with joe biden that's
what we're going to do
with california liberal senator kamala
harris we're just going to
tell the american people where they want
to go i mean it is an amazing thing to
think about
i mean here we are in the midst of a
global pandemic
and we grieve for the loss of more than
000 americans we've been working 24
hours a day
to have the testing to have the
equipment to have the medical supplies
to have the medicines we're driving
relentlessly
toward a vaccine but what we're also
doing is we're opening up america again
i mean we've literally seen nine million
americans go
back to work and reclaim
jobs in this economy um in the last
three months alone
opening up our schools all across the
country but joe biden and kamala harris
want to raise taxes by 4 trillion
dollars they want to impose a two
trillion dollar version
of the green new deal at a time when the
american economy is recovering
and and we're adding jobs back at
a historic pace their prescription
alone for the economy would would crush
the vitality out of the recovery that's
underway and i
i just think presenting all of those
facts laying out the contrast in the
choice in this election i truly do
believe that
that you know president trump
demonstrated in our first three years
that we could be strong again we could
be prosperous again
by advancing policies of less taxes less
regulation more american energy
free and fair trade standing on our
highest
constitutional principles of life and
liberty in the second amendment
their policies would not only crush the
vitality out of this economy to take us
on a leftward turn
of socialism and decline and when we
frame
that choice for the american people uh i
i uh it i i'm i'm very confident we're
gonna win four more years
for president donald trump in the white
house and vice president pence how do
you plan to fend off the attacks from
the media that any critique of kamala
harris
is in fact a reflection of sexism and
racism we've seen this narrative being
trotted out
that if president trump calls her phony
it's because it's a sexist or racist
attack that if he says her treatment of
brett kavanaugh was nasty which
technically it was uh that that is a
reflection of sexism and racism how do
you plan to fight back against those
charges
well we're just gonna we're gonna deal
with it the facts every
single step of the way and and uh look
the media is gonna do what the media is
gonna to do
i have to tell you i was uh i was i was
chuckling
the other day when i heard that the new
york times had done a story describing
the most
liberal member of the united states
senate as a moderate
as a pragmatic moderate and then and
then you saw newspapers and
and uh and also um you know their
adherence on a couple of the major cable
networks repeating the same language but
look i think
it kind of reminds me of what groucho
marx said years ago
he said who are you going to believe me
or your own eyes
right i mean the democrats and the
liberals in the media
you know want to say no believe us when
we try and tell you as he as now joe
biden's campaign is trying to say that
he's a moderate
but the american people see it i mean
they see it
plans to raise taxes by trillions of
dollars they see a march towards
socialized medicine a commitment to
open borders and and and health benefits
for
illegal immigrants they see it abortion
on demand taxpayer funding
of abortion and and i think most
appointed of all and you've talked a lot
about this ben but
you know at a time when we see a rise of
heartbreaking violence tearing apart our
cities in new york and seattle and
portland and chicago
you've got joe biden he's asked if he'd
be willing to cut
funding to law enforcement he said yes
absolutely
you have you have his running mate who
said uh
who said that it was time to quote
reimagine law enforcement i
i have to tell you that that that's
when i was in iowa yesterday i was
surrounded in a barn by law enforcement
officers and their families
i'm i believe with all of my heart that
when we lay out that agenda
when we stick to those facts we give the
american people a clear choice
they're going to choose to reelect
president donald trump and and support
an agenda that made america great
in three short years it's going to make
america great again again
with four more years vice president mike
pence really appreciate your time
congratulations on
entering a politically target rich
environment i appreciate it
and good luck sir
thanks ben great to be back on the bench
bureau show
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content